This has been my favorite late night snack lately.
It's way past my bedtime,
but I needed a snack,
so this is what I've been having.
It's honey crisp apples.
I slice them. Sometimes I take the skin off.
They have to be cold.
And then I made date caramel.
You can also use normal caramel,
whatever you want.
I just soaked some dates,
blended them up.
It tastes like caramel.
It's so good. And then I sprinkle some flaky sea salt on top.
So this is what I do.
Take my apple,
get a good amount of caramel on it,
some flaky sea salt.
Wow.
I also sometimes do this with bananas or strawberries,
but apples are my favorite.
There's something about the combination of apples and caramel.
And the flaky sea salt is crunchy on top of it,
but also it just tastes like salted caramel.